I just found out about this really
interesting new trend where single
people or even people that are married
or whatever people that want to have
kids immediately are getting on these
websites to meet other people that want
to have kids
and then their co-parents so they're
skipping the romance they're skipping
the dating they get to [ __ ] don't wait
the question is do they [ __ ] how are
they giving these kids [ __ ] so
there's there's you could do that way or
they have like a lot of these websites
they have like resources for you to do
like in vitro it's like oh wow at least
get some [ __ ] out of it if you want to
do that but pretty much what's happening
it's kind of like on dating websites you
know you're looking for a potential
partner for romance reasons right but in
these particular websites they are only
searching other people that like if you
would be a good match as a parent that's
so gross so would it be like fine I
think parents calm like you can just
help them raise their kid
picture this okay I'm single you're
single okay and we both want to have a
baby
and then we both have similar interests
and how we want to raise our kids and
then we just decide to link up and be
like hey you want to be a co-parent we
don't have to be in a relationship oh
you guys just boned get pregnant but
nothing else in between depending on the
culture they live together or is it like
almost like a divorce exactly how they
would describe it it's kind of like well
obviously divorce without the baggage
exactly that's kind of how they're
saying like a lota kid but only
sometimes take them out and if you add
like a divorce relationship like you
just really want to bring a kid into the
world but you just don't want to waste
the waste the time of like finding
someone like falling in love getting
married or whatever and then what if
like you're just not romantically
compatible but you really want to bring
a kid into the world now and so they're
going to these websites like some of the
websites are called like co-parents com
you should call it come in me calm
hey-yah one of it yeah what it is is
it's basically hate do you want to go
broke together is
because we're a little [ __ ] wording
that's true it's like I can I can
imagine like someone that just got
divorced never had kids of that person
yeah right but then they're like maybe
in the middle of the 30s you know and
they're like what clocks kind of tickin
like I got a if I want to have a baby
but to get into a new relationship that
takes time you know takes time to
nurture the relationship to get to
marriage to get to having a baby so I
could see how this works I really wonder
how this works
like legally like paper wise because if
you wanted to adopt a child and you go
into the adoption center and you're like
yeah we're not together
we're just gonna do this together how
would that work well if they adopt huh
yeah that's if they decide to go the
adoptive way but they are saying that
there's something there are like married
people on this site where for example
the me and Casey right like Casey really
were really wants to have a kid and I
don't then we have a discussion he goes
to his website he finds someone that
have sex with someone else that's why I
Beach will make sense cuz then if you
are married you don't want the partner
to have sex yeah and also interestingly
enough legally the biological parents
have custody of the kids so I would not
be legally in the picture even though
I'm married to him what if Casey was
having sex with you but right when he's
about the bust he puts in the other
person that's true no it can get messy
because like what if it sounds like a
legal nightmare yeah cuz that could get
messy like the comes gonna spill
everywhere like that's that's gonna get
messy the concept is pretty cool though
we're like if there's two people I just
want to have kids together and they're
on the same page and they don't want to
have all the other romance and marriage
like baggage or whatever that might make
me come quick or two if I'm [ __ ]
somebody and the hot girls watching me
and then at the last moment I got a
[ __ ] time it did come in her I do
that often sounds harder actually at her
that's true you got to make sure she's
ovulating
yes oh it's a timing thing this might be
like a legal nightmare because what if
that happens and then Tiff's like well
it's not my biological child but I love
that kid I've raised since I was kid you
know like her since it was a infant so
that might get weird you attached to
things too easily [ __ ] babies yeah
[ __ ] [ __ ] either there's people
coming into this conversation being like
wait why don't you just have a kid by
yourself then if you want one so bad
well what they I do jack off in their
mouths but then people that are going
this route they're saying like well I
want my child to grow up with two
parents like I don't want to be
everything but will there be two parents
if they're not living under the core
parents gonna live together then
probably not you're basically you
created a baby your baby knowing that's
gonna be a broken home from they get
yeah there is no chance of having it
it's like oh is it broken if it was
never together
it's an unbroken home but it's it very I
mean but thinking from the this is her
this is my do you think our home is
broken
no but it wasn't it wasn't like it was I
don't know here's mine here's my thought
process on that thing which is it feels
really selfish on the grown-ups part
they just want it it's self-serving that
they want a child but then I'm thinking
like you know the kid's life and how
they're gonna grow up to the routine is
kind of what they need and it's very
unstable because you don't know whose
house you're going to what day right
yeah yeah cause like I like raising
Isaac it's like we if we Hanna mom's
yeah I mean I guess it wouldn't be as
bad because the other one would be like
you guys are trying to fight to figure
out which days would work but this one
they agree before they even get the gam
before you're not the kid but no this
makes you feel like the kid is kind of a
[ __ ] accessory
yes and it feels weird yeah it's just
like well I don't really want I just
want a kid you guys would just wanna
make a [ __ ] kid you know and it's
also like kids I actually kind of
curious to see how anti-gay people who
say oh yeah it's not a healthy family if
it's two men or two women raising a kid
what if it's two people who don't have
any feelings for each other or just
two separate people you know like how
would you feel about that would you
rather have two strangers raise a kid or
two people at the same sex that actually
love each other that feels more of like
the I guess not broken home and there's
an actual house well it's because it
takes a team to raise a kid yeah that
feels more like a team rather than like
to outsource teammates and then also
like in school they're gonna be like oh
you know we're gonna do projects on your
parents and this kid's gonna be like oh
my parents are just two people they
don't love each other they're just two
people yeah that they point out in this
article where like that would be the
thing that the child misses out on is
seeing the dynamics of a household
loving a loving couple a lot of kids
grow up like that today that's why I was
thinking too I'm like well there's like
millions and millions and millions of
homes that are already doing this with
people actually it's even worse because
people that get divorced and they have a
kid like they are not mostly a hate each
other
terms actually it's very toxic they use
the kid against each other and but at
least in this situation there's a mutual
respect for each part of each parent and
it's like well hey we're just trying to
make this thing happen let's [ __ ] do
this thing something's gonna go bad
along the line though because like if I
can change people change four-year-olds
like well no I want to put interaction
obligated I don't know if you could even
all contrasting to renegotiate it what
we think is a healthy or normal or
what's supposed to be is just a recent
construct where this isn't how humans
have been like I recently watched this
one travel vlogging food guy that goes
to different like weird places and like
he was with a tribe and he was
explaining how like this one tribe the
kid never is alone because the God there
so there's all they can have multiple
wives in this tribe but also everyone
takes care of everyone so like let's say
not even the mom is breastfeeding the
baby right and she goes oh [ __ ] I left
the pot running I got to go handle that
she'll pass all over the kid to another
lady that would take take care of the
kid and watch him for a little bit and
then so she's taking care of that and
then she'll be like oh [ __ ] the goats
right and then she'll pass through the
next kid but there's
always someone there and in if a baby
starts crying then anybody next to the
baby
whether it be like chief leader lady guy
brother they just picked the baby up in
like so then they have this feeling of
comfort I think that's more important
than these rules so like true imagine if
you come from a big family and
everyone's there then you grow up with a
lot of support right versus like if
you're extremely lonely and your parents
always working you you can come from a
family where there's two parents but if
they're constantly working and busy you
know like which one's more healthier and
I think that our idea of this nuclear
family like mom dad kids in one
household I think that is a new thing
like that isn't traditional
traditionally like there's been times
with like in Europe where the way that
the Vikings would live is everyone lived
in one big-ass longhouse all the family
members and friends and everybody of
that tribe lived in that one house and
the crazy [ __ ] is don't [ __ ] in there
they'll eat in there they'll do
everything in in the close quarters
together that's always thinking that the
cult parents live together that'd be
pretty cool it's like to people that are
just individuals and another just passed
and there's like no real family no real
support and they just passing kid back
and forth yeah it's like it's like the
same as going from daycare to daycare to
daycare because I think neglect is worse
for the child than any other structure
well you have like 10 gay daddies but I
I think that's even healthier than being
a neglected child yeah absolutely I do
wonder like what's gonna happen like say
one one day along the lines one parent
starts dating someone and then this
parents like I don't like that guy I
don't like how he treats my kid like
it's gonna get messy yeah weird
there's definitely a lot of
unforeseeable like things that will
definitely pumped even in a in a nucleus
family like the type of families that
we're talking about that's like very
traditional my mom and dad are there
they're very you know they pay attention
to the kids but like life itself is
gonna throw some wrenches in there and
like you have to figure it out and I
just feel like this this direction all
right feel like that unforseen well
stuff is present no matter what I win
say it's more or less than any situation
yeah cuz you got to think about the
individual right what if they're two
like you said older people who never had
that time to develop the love in the
traditional thing right yeah let's say
she's pushing mid-30s he's in his 40s
and he's just like I just want an
intelligent successful like partner that
maybe I don't want to get romantically
involved with but I know that she's good
she's I just want to come in her real
quick go to cream pie homies calm you
know
that's my side cream pie homies calm
okay so say like say divorce couple at
one point these two actually really love
each other imagine like they're so and
now they're so shitty to each other
because of a divorce even though they
had the connection now imagine if
something goes wrong with two people who
never had that connection I couldn't get
even worse I don't know about what I
think it's without the baggage there's
no there's no there's no baggage mutual
respect coming into the situation
already with the understanding of like
this is where we're at I think I would
prefer the latter
you always have respect oh it's easier
because divorce is like you broke the
respect and that's why you're going
through the divorce right so like if
you've always had respect from the
beginning it's kind of like the way I
say this is like an arranged marriage
we're two parents get together because
their parents chose it right
their parents chose these two kids to
get married they didn't want to marry
each other but they have an obligation
and they made an agreement and sometimes
they don't work but sometimes they do
work sometimes they fall in love later
too so yeah you never know and in this
situation it's like how do we know or
how can we predict that it's gonna be
not working
I feel like culture is constantly gonna
change the way that we see marriage
today is not how our parents saw it it's
gonna continuously change so I think
that when I hear things like this I were
just judging based off of what we think
should happen but it sounds kind of
healthy to me that's what I said I was
like that's tight like find your
solution educated the blessing alright
let's do it so
we're signing up oh we're signing up
because I don't want to get oh yeah
right okay have you gone the wrong juicy
one kids - all right right yes well both
me I know that work again dog each other
we got to cover each other's mouths
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]